the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
so last time we talked to best are
spectacular things about human nature in
terms of problems with a difficulties
when we overly obey when we're overly
conformist and the tendency for us to do
that much more than we imagined we would
and the experimental evidence is pretty
powerful that's true
you could call it a dark side of things
like obedience and conformity the upside
is that's how we work together and get
along as a society and today I'm going
to focus more as an individual every day
experiences but again I think you'll see
in terms of self-concept and impressions
of others is there more everyday kinds
of things but you see how they populate
our lives how we think about ourselves
how we think about people on everyday
interactions impressions of others we
haven't we talked a little bit just a
little bit about cultural differences
our course has been very focused on
American European type cultures we
talked a little bit about different ones
I'll say a bit more about that and then
I'll talk about maybe the most thought
about disorder of social interaction
autism so enhancing our views of
ourselves okay so most us college
students rate themselves as better than
average students all right so you could
sit there in your chair and you could go
no I'm pretty modest person but really a
better than the average student right
and by the way I'll tell you faculties
things are the same okay so a million
high school students rated their leader
their leadership abilities in one
example 28% they said they were average
70 70 percent rated themselves as
above-average in leadership right right
you you understand that only 50 percent
could be at most above-average or 49
right only two percent said they were
below average sixty percent of the high
school students of these millions said
they were they were in the top 10% in
the ability he'll get along with others
okay
all right now and by the way just in
case you think is picking on students
ninety-four percent of college
instructors are raised in themselves as
better than average teachers so whether
you're sitting there or you're standing
here you know we all polish our image to
ourselves and we can decide is that a
bad thing is that vanity or egoism or is
that maybe a pretty healthy way to bump
through life okay
is is over rating yourself short of
putting yourself in disruptive
situations is that a way to be happy and
optimistic resilience so people call
this self-serving attributional biases
and this will play out a little bit like
the fundamental attribution error let me
remind you of what that is the
fundamental attribution error is when
other people do things it's their
character and especially failings are
because of failings of their character
when we do things we're not especially
proud of or don't think are awesome
that's the situation that made us do it
and we don't provide that same
understanding of the situation to
understand the behaviors of others it's
not intuitive to do stuff so they did
experiments where they where the
experimenters setup how well you would
do on test they made a test super
difficult or easier sensory or
perceptual discriminations social
sensitivity competitive games it's all
set up by the experimenter they can make
tests brutally hard or pretty easy right
they can make you do well or make you do
badly and when people did well and they
were asked to say why they thought they
did well the usual description was
because I'm a particularly social person
I'm very competitive I'm extra good at
sensory perception you know you pick it
when they did badly that was a tough
test okay nobody it's rare for people to
say that was an easy test who wouldn't
do well alright if you do well people
tend to ascribe it to their character
and when they do badly the situation so
even within ourselves that and it
extends to family social and political
groups and sports teams I mean you may
know like I I'm very proud and happy to
be a member of the MIT community
something happens bad at MIT I don't go
well didn't MIT stinks right I go oh
there was a situation that wasn't well
handled by an individual right okay same
thing you know you might think about the
country you belong to
we don't say us to something bad most of
us don't go well u.s. stinks we go that
situation wasn't very good we got to
change things you know yeah
so the question was is it what they
actually believe are say things to
others I think the evidence is it's
about what they say to themselves truly
about how to explain success or failure
okay
so a black people are biased to you know
attribute their successes to their
wonderful traits and their failures to
situations but we talked earlier that
that can be a healthy thing right
because then you can bounce back you can
say well I did badly but hey I'm a
winner
and then on tomorrow morning I'll get up
and I'm back at the bet right okay
instead of saying oh I'm a loser it's
all just pointless right so so you know
in what sense it's good to have this
it's not a good thing or a bad thing
it's probably a thing of positive mental
health but it can make us overlook
causes of things so an example of that
as we construct social realities and you
may know this this is the original study
but there's a million sense where they
took a undefeated Princeton team play
Dartmouth in a football game
Princeton won and then they looked at
the newspaper accounts of the games who
are totally different they showed the
film to students from the two campuses
and depending on which team you were
rooting for you tended to view the other
team as you know dirty not playing fair
not doing the right thing you don't have
to be much of a sports fan to you know
notice things where the other team is
not doing the right thing in your team
when it doesn't do the right thing well
they were under pressure or it was a
typical you know right yeah okay so and
that makes it of course hard for people
to get together we don't too much worry
about Princeton Dartmouth tension in the
world but we do worry about tensions
pretend in the Middle East between
Palestinians and Israelis you know they
see the same news story how do they
interpret what happened in that news
story so this question of if we have
illusions that we're sort of better than
we are a little bit is that a bad thing
or is that a good thing was tested in a
sort of ironic study by alloy and
Abramson looking at patients with actual
clinical depression so they gave
depressed and non depressed students
tasks the very did degree of contingency
that is how much the performance of the
participant actually influenced the
outcome they controlled that
and then they asked people afterwards to
estimate the degree of contingency
between a button press and a green light
going on how much of it was you and how
much of it seemed to be randomly done by
the experimenter the press students in
this particular study we're more
accurate in knowing when it was
dependent on them and non depressed
students overestimated the contingency
they overestimated their influence on
the situation when the outcomes were
desired awesome that's because I'm
awesome alright and when things didn't
go so well again not really under their
control but they don't know that it's
the situation something was screwed up
with the experiment okay so they're more
variable they interpret the situation
much more again on these things and you
can say they're less accurately you
could also say that's a way again to
have confidence in yourself and optimism
about the future another way in which we
sort of believe in justify our choices
but a ways at which were socially
influences this well the phenomenon
called false consensus that people
choose to engage in a behavior that
those people who do that believe that
it's more common and that more people do
that that when you do something the more
you do it the more you think other
people do it too what's the big deal
right you might know that feeling
so the original experiment on the
Stanford campus for this phenomenon from
Lee Ross was he asked people to carry
around a sign on campus that said eat at
Joe's okay for 30 minutes some people
said like no thank you
some people said yes because they were
obedient okay
compliance now of the people who said
yes I'll carry that sign for 30 minutes
they thought the majority of other
people when asked to do so will do so
okay they thought well that's the way
most people are and I'm gonna behave
like most people that's a false
consensus the people who said no I won't
do it they thought only the majority
would not do it so part of their
thinking about deciding if they'll do
something or not is their estimate of
whether people in general would do it
but what you could see it happens is
that's driven by whether they're going
to do it or not all right so for example
teenage smokers estimate higher rates of
smoking than non-smokers domestic abuse
domestically abusive men estimated about
28% of men and violently throwing things
at their partner
best estimates are this down to 12% so
you know we tend to overly believe that
other people will do the same behaviors
that we do and that's part of justifying
those behaviors as sort of demonstration
that was from Phil Zimbardo the social
psychologist who did the Prison
Experiment this is some of the same
flavor not quite as dramatic but he
worked in New York before he moved to
Stanford so he compared the Bronx to
Palo Alto in 1980 was the paper
published and he left out cars one in an
upper-middle-class Palo Alto very
suburban area if you haven't been there
at one in a tough Bronx area you can
imagine you leave a car out there by
itself in the Bronx area without a
license plate and the hood was up it was
stripped within a day see park a car you
push up the hood no license plate
stripped within a day in Palo Alto it's
untouched for a week okay so that's it
supposed to do with the environment
you're in but then here's the false
consensus so then they smash a window
and within an hour it stripped right as
soon as you sent the smashed window we
talked about broken windows here it is
literally okay soon as somebody says you
know that all rules are off this car you
know smashed wrecked that's the behavior
I can engage in okay so it's not okay so
it's the the what you what you perceive
as the relevant sort of environment of
behaviors that are appropriate hugely
influences and justifies and drives your
own behavior now one of the tasks people
have to try to convince people to do
public goods in various ways and this is
an ad that when I was younger was very
famous I mean for you it's so long ago
in history that you may not even know it
but it was one of the most famous ones
when the United States was first
confronting issues with environmental
problems and pollution you you may not
believe there was an era when there was
fantastic pollution in the air and the
water and the land and nobody seemed to
care about it at all because land seemed
endless it wasn't even a thought okay so
was Earth Day was from the 1970s you
know that was kind of marking of a wider
consciousness of the consequence of
ruining the environment and so in the
very earliest stages when people weren't
used to sort of almost any discussion of
that there was this ad
with a Native American with a tear
running down his face and let me show
you the ad
a very powerful
ad at a time and one that I'll show you
in a minute
psych social psychologists believe was
completely counterproductive to the goal
of reducing pollution exactly the thing
you don't want to do okay because we
just talked about false consensus and
about these environmental justification
so I'll tell you but let's let's just
use what does that mean so if you see a
lot of people throwing garbage onto the
beach onto the street into the river
what's what are you allowed to do
pollute yourself everybody else is
throwing here you know what's the big
deal that's the mode of behavior right
broken window steal the car litter
everywhere okay somebody's saying it's
not a good idea but I that the behavior
I see is littering littering littering
it's okay to litter so they literally
show this in experiments they took
people into areas into parks they
surrounded them with different amounts
of trash here's here's a percentage of
people who littered here's how much
trash was around them they went into
parks and they put a little trash they
watched somebody come by still some
people are littering maybe less wood now
I don't know but as soon as there was
four pieces or eight pieces of littering
then you more than double the littering
when there's zero so the very example of
showing littering drives littering you
say you know nobody's saying it's a good
thing but hey it's what everybody's
doing okay and why do we literally Z and
we just don't most of us don't just want
to bother to walk to the garbage can
right okay so they did an experiment
with public service announcements where
they said the important thing is to see
behaviors that the behavior you want
like in this case it was a recycling
thing and then some you saw one example
of a person who doesn't do it and you
say bad person you don't say that person
but you send that message you so here's
the behavior we want there's somebody
doing that okay and what they found is a
25 percent this is truly in the
community increase in recycling so if
you want to get people to do things
showing them dad behavior unfortunately
makes them think that bad behavior is
widespread and acceptable way to go so
you have to show them good behavior
then give maybe one example of bad
things to because you don't want to be
labeled bad okay but mostly they have to
see the behavior you want not the
behavior trying to discourage so it you
know from a social psychologist exactly
the opposite and outcome of the intended
ad so this speaks to a gap we almost all
of us have I mean some of you may be
more perfect than I mean many of you may
be more perfect than I but here's the
gap we face every morning when we get up
which is the difference between our
attitudes and our actions the things we
know are the way we wish we were the
right thing to do and the way in which
sometimes we don't always do the
rightest thing you know we could so
daffodil days you may know many places
clean universities where you buy a
daffodil and there's a four-day campus
event to benefit American Cancer Society
so it's it's a nice thing it's buying a
flower it's a good cause fighting cancer
right very positive so they went to a
study with 251 Cornell students and they
asked them when daffodil day comes up
and you just spent a tiny bit of money
it's a very small amount of money they
ask for students will you buy at least
one flower and a tea over 80% said yes I
will for a cause like that you know
buying a beautiful flower to fight
cancer you know I'll spend a dollar how
about the other students well they're
kind of lazy and the good intentions but
probably only about half of them will do
it that's a little bit of the self
affirmation right I'm a good person
other people a little bit flawed alright
so how many people actually buy it 43
percent so what happened to this forty
percent well it's a little bit like the
story they were busy things were
happening is that they weren't for
cancer and against flowers right just
they got busy you know your exams there
were stuff going on you know so uh yeah
and how do we explain to ourselves this
gap between the attitudes we hold and
truly hold right that we want to do good
things and be a good person and the
actions we do which are often a little
bit below that so this gap between our
attitudes and our actions has led to the
phenomenon of cognitive dissonance you
now hear this term used widely
originally had a pretty narrow meaning
I'm going to be just talking about that
narrow meaning because we
a term that's going to use much more
widely but here's original you work from
fest injure so he said that we have a
problem all the time that we have a gap
between our attitudes and our behaviors
and that as humans we have to solve this
because we don't feel good about that
gap and so here's how he approached
showing how we solved that problem of
course the nice thing would be just do
the right thing all the time but that's
not within our most of our somehow our
grasp okay so here's what he had people
do he had people come in and do a
purposefully boring task so they would
pack and unpack spools in a tray or they
would turn tiny little screws each of
them a quarter thing
it was purposefully boring you could
tell was boring and it was boring okay
this is the goal and then either nothing
would happen that's one group or you
would get paid a dollar not much money
or twenty dollars considerably better to
lie and tell the next person who's
coming in that this was an interesting
and worthwhile task okay so you imagine
you go in there you do something that's
really boring imagine you're in this
group they say here here's a dollar will
you lied to the next person and or
here's $20 we a lie to the next person
saying this was a pretty cool task you
know I can't believe how lucky you are
to have the next term and then they say
okay now we know you lied to that person
we asked you to do it but really really
how was the task really really how was a
task and here's the amazing finding if
you don't lie you say I didn't like it
very much at all here's zero less than
zero if you were paid a dollar to lie
whoa
it really was good if you paid twenty
dollars to lie you pretty much agree it
stinks okay so how is that work you have
to see the irony of this right so the
iron the interpretation is this if
somebody pays you $20 to make a white
lie you don't see this as a brutal eye
right just telling the next student that
this is a pretty cool task right it's
$20 worth of white lie you can live with
that you know why you did it but a
dollar would you sacrifice your
integrity for a dollar okay
so so you and Stephanie a dollar how
cheap can you be right okay so their
idea is this but now they're asking them
really really really really the way that
people put together their attitudes like
I lied for a mere dollars to say hey it
must have been more interesting than I
first thought
come to think of it it was pretty
interesting boom do you understand that
so the effort to match up the
discrepancy between your attitudes and
actions you solve you you can't let them
go like this you can explain this I lied
cuz I got paid a bunch this you can't
explain it's too hard to understand and
you really create a rationalization that
puts it all together and you really
really report now that this was a pretty
good task okay
here's another one and this is this is
not high tech experiments you can do
amazing experiments you know without
zapping people and when I tell you by
time I tell you the end of this this one
experiment let's see if I have one more
on this
yeah I'll say this I mention it now
that's going the next one I've been sort
of it pretty much ruins it whenever
anybody tells you how satisfied they are
with almost anything they've done in
their life this has ruined it for me
okay I'll tell you all right although I
know that you're better off have
polishing your your happiness right so
here's this simple experiment this guy
Jack Brown had a bunch of wedding gifts
and he took his wedding gifts to the lab
okay was it not very high-tech and yep
people rate how much they wanted them so
he had stuff like a desk lamp a toaster
a stopwatch a radio a bunch of stuff you
get in the 1950s as wedding gifts people
rated how much do they like them and
then he picked two that were kind of in
the middle of the list and rate of right
next to each other all right and he said
will you pick one of these two you get
to take it home really pick one of these
two that you rated in the middle right
next to each other and you pick one he
said okay do one more thing before you
take it home tell me again your ratings
for the different things here and here's
what they find that the item that you
chose moves up you already have it but
where it let's say this weighted one to
ten it was rated a 5 it now becomes a 2
man that stopwatch
that's pretty awesome you know I thought
it was a five but it's a two maybe a one
I can't believe lucky I am that I picked
that okay and how about the one you
didn't pick say the toaster was number
six or number four they have moved on
nine or ten that toaster stinks that
would have been such a bad choice to
attend Harvard it would have been a
disaster thank goodness I picked MIT
okay so the idea is even something like
this and everything that do college
choices cars any experiment you do if
you have people rate after they've made
a decision about what they're gonna do
they always rate the thing they picked
is awesome on average and the thing they
didn't pick as much worse than they
initially rated it and again you can say
is is that a way we can have a happy
life would you want to be at MIT every
day going if only I had gone to
Princeton would you want to get married
to somebody and say if only I had waited
a little bit longer
all right would you for your career
could you have said I went right to
medical school or law school or
engineering if only I would write so you
want to say no thank goodness I picked
that College thank goodness I picked
that career thank goodness I picked that
spouse or partner because the other
choices that are vaguely in my head were
awful I don't know how I was even
thinking about them right so so this is
ruined it for me every but time guy
tells me how happy they are with a
choice they've made in their life
because I look at this and go yeah once
you make that choice
you're gonna rate it as awesome no
matter what okay a famous example is now
many of you are taking pretty tough
courses years later when you come back
to for alumni events and hopefully many
of you will have good feelings about MIT
and come back and see your classmates
and you will get around and say oh that
course was so brutal I know that won't
be this course okay that course was so
brutal with the problem sets but it made
me a stronger person a better person
thank goodness I did it right okay and
maybe it does but let me tell you why
you will think that in large numbers
okay so 1959's a little bit of a
sociological experiment and essentially
to think of people in 1959 and they were
told to qualify for a research study
some women were required to read aloud a
list of obscene words which was seen as
extremely embarrassing and unappropriate
in 1959 nowadays that might be the
preferred mode
right okay but in 1959 is like I don't
know this is not right okay or mild
words so that's an experimenter then
you've got the privilege if you did this
to listen to a lecture on mating habits
of lower animals but they made it the
most boring they could not that this you
know this could go a couple of different
ways mating habits of lower animals they
made it super boring on purpose okay
lectures over and they asked the
students to rate the lecture a superb or
intentionally super boring lecture and
the women were either in the group for
the unpleasant experience of having to
read aloud uncomfortable word lists or
just neutral words no big deal who rated
the lecture better the women who read
the obscene list of words because they
were saying well why would I do this if
the lecture weren't terrific okay so the
worse the experience the more it is you
know where you've had some feel some
sense of choice in it the more people
will explain to themselves I took it for
an extremely good reason I would not
take do a painful thing I'm not that
incompetent it must have been a wise
decision in fact I should tell you that
if the examiner picks these items you
don't have much of an effect so if you
rate items you know four and five or
five and six and examiner's gives you
the stopwatch you still it doesn't
change your ratings because you didn't
choose it the examiner did the stopwatch
is mediocre gift is still a mediocre
gift okay but if you chose it you have
to justify the choice so and it's you
know there's a thousand experiments like
this why did I do something so painful
it must have been for a very good reason
okay and then you figure out what that
reason was like the lecture was more
awesome than I thought that physics
course that math course that computer
science course just made me the person I
am today right okay you know switch
gears now first impressions so there's a
book from Malcom Gladwell blink which is
really driven by this phenomenon the
first impressions we take of other
people how powerful are they how valid
are they where you know how accurate are
they so here's how we're going to start
the story all the way back in 1966 they
had students write people's personality
and the first day of class before they
met each other so if we had done that
in this course I mentioned the first day
of this course imagine you're not
sitting with a friend and you're asked
to rate people around you on various
personality dimensions and the two that
popped out were sociable and
responsibility the people who said they
were sociable people tended the random
sociable just from sitting next to them
for a moment or as highly responsible so
this is outgoingness in personality
psychology or extraversion and this is
something like conscientiousness just
talk to a person for a couple of moments
you rate them pretty much like they rate
themselves you don't know anything about
their background you haven't had a big
interaction literally it's moments next
to each other of course there's another
one 250 students divided into four
groups who didn't know divide into
groups of four who didn't know each
other and had not spoken and they rated
each other and there was pretty good
correlations between moments of energy
sitting together and how sociable or how
extroverted people were responsible
sorry conscientiousness so a few moments
with somebody correlates pretty well
your rating on average with how they
know themselves from a lifetime of
personal experience a few moments pretty
well now we could say how good do we
rate how well do we rate ourselves you
could already say pretty well because
it's pretty well adjusted with what
other people think but here's an another
example where they put strangers into
groups videotaped them had other people
later on view the videotapes and rate
things like how extroverted would they
were how much time do they talk how many
are movements the impressions of the
judges watching the video tape
correlated pretty well with self ratings
and with ratings of other people who saw
them just for a few moments personally
so all these things line up just from a
few moments of experience you get a
surprisingly strong consensus about how
outgoing somebody is and how
conscientious were responsible they are
and it lines up pretty much with the
person's own judgement about themselves
that way so this reached a sort of a
huge moment from now on the embody is
now attests having this famous
experiment thin slices okay it's a
fantastic experiment and if you ever
teach it makes you nervous then we'll
discuss whether it should or not okay so
at Harvard here's what she did she took
videotapes of 13 graduate teaching
assistants and they were horrible
vo tapes this is 1990 they were horrible
videotapes I just gotta tell you you
don't even see them around very much
because they're the quality when you see
them you get sort of you can't believe
people even saw things in them okay
alright and she she took she she got a
random 10-second clips 30 seconds per
teaching assistants 30 seconds she shows
a silent clip to students there's no
sound even you're just seeing silently
some teaching assistant in front of
students saying something and then she
has these students rate from the silent
film clip how accepting active competent
or confident the teaching assistant is
who they've never met and of course they
don't know and they don't know what the
teaching assistants talking about here's
the impressive thing then they correlate
the ratings with the actual end of
semester rating with students they take
the students who've sat through the
entire course with a teaching assistant
that's one set of values they take the
students to see 30 seconds of silent
grainy videotape and they say how well
do these things two together and they
correlate 0.76 which is really high okay
it's really high in our really research
that that momentary uninformed
impression correlates extremely high
with what students rate the teaching
assistant after a full semester back and
forth seeing the teaching assistant you
know day in day out week in week out for
an entire semester and all the
interactions super high correlation and
it stays if it's cut from 30 seconds to
15 or even 6 seconds so this is a thin
slice a tiny viewing of somebody has
this a profound effect so um so one
impression you can have from this is
something like gee we form a first
impression and I'll come back to that
and once we further them that first
impression that's it the ship has sailed
to a remarkable degree it can't be you
know if we can learn new things about
people we can change our impressions
it's not that we can't but to a
remarkable degree we've set our final
impression of that person within seconds
of an interaction it's kind of great you
could say and of course that's gonna be
fraught with every kind of social
prejudice you can imagine and
complicating prejudice you can imagine
six seconds and I'll have to sort
through and
and it shows up in real life for example
listen to 20 seconds of a physician
speaking during a routine office visit
they tape recorded them above chance
prediction of who was sued for
malpractice or not because if you like a
doctor you tend to forgive an error as a
human error if you don't like a doctor
you know you're gonna sue that person
because you're pretty mad at them okay
so do you give them a benefit the doubt
they made a mistake or do you think they
ought to be sued and punished for the
bad thing they did with you depends how
much you like the person to start with
now so one thing could be that we go by
first impressions we're just what's the
other possibility you could imagine this
is the bat it you know the the
pessimistic view of this is and it's
somewhere I think really in the middle
is just human nature the pessimistic
view is six seconds
when we talk about this the teaching
assistants and I as we begin the course
go oh please have the first six seconds
go okay you know because that's going to
be 3/4 of your teaching evaluations
which are due Monday by 9:00 a.m. okay
all right so uh so please fill those out
by the way there sir reminds me but yeah
the first six seconds and that's pretty
much it and everything we do for the
rest of the semester everything we do
for there semester is only gonna be
about a quarter of your rating that's
hard to believe right so one thing is
it's all a big confusion and humans just
what's the other possibility that's a
little bit more optimistic and maybe
accurate we know what we like we know
what we like okay and amazingly we can
tell within seconds under many
circumstance
whether there's something about a person
that we like or don't that is not that
the six seconds are just superficial in
a dumb way it's we detect things about
that person that truly are something
about who they are and that tends to
carry all the way through our human
interactions with them so it's I think
you notice it's somewhere in that range
and does it matter is that all just
about popularity contest or does it
affect other things of staying within
the realm of teaching they looked at
they asked if you perceive somebody as
you know more likeable or conscientious
are they more effective teachers as a
server visits circle around like that so
they had five students in random groups
one was randomly chosen to be a teacher
and these teachers prepared brief math
lessons the students then took the test
and Strangers rated 10 seconds of videos
of these teachers so you know people
prepared math lessons some better some
worse as you would imagine the higher
these were rated in these 10-second
thin-sliced videos by an external group
the better the test scores of the actual
participants because something about
effective teaching is something about
engaging students something about
engaging students is something about
being outgoing or something like that to
a certain degree so it's not just
arbitrary there's something real in the
world that happens and here's a few
examples where people have messed around
with that because there's two things
that happen that are tricky one is we
know what we like and we detect it
amazingly quickly in people on average
to a large extent with certainly with
error but to a surprisingly rigorous
extent on the other hand and we'll come
back to this once we have that first
impression as faulty as it may be in
part we keep interpreting things in
terms of that first impression right we
give you the benefit of the doubt where
we don't have behavior after behavior so
you just study that was done in MIT
where now you're gonna get some prior
information with half the students were
told the lecture you're about to have
people know him
consider him to be uh and then here's
the to you in the group that's told he's
a very warm person industrious critical
practical and determined or half of you
would get the information that he's a
cold person industrious critical
practical and determined okay say you
just got an impression a warm up cold
person you haven't even seen the person
person gets up and gives a 20 to 20
minute discussion then you're asked to
fill out evaluations let me just pick
the example of the warm person the
lecturer is rated as better but here's
the really cool part students took more
part in discussion and do you see how
they've probably made the section better
okay because if you think this is a nice
person so I can make a comment I won't
get my head bit off that I didn't do the
reading or whatever you know it makes a
section better they think is better but
they make it better because something
the person is a person they want to
interact with simply because they were
told on a piece of paper the person is
warm or cold
the person's identical
I'm after time so the first impression
we know what we like is surprisingly
accurate in certain ways but we it's
hard to change because new information
is interpreted to be consistent with
already formed impressions so first
impressions are unbelievably interesting
because they seem to be so powerful in
how we choose who we like and don't like
who we hire and don't hire who we work
with and don't work with who we have
relationships and don't have
relationships with and they're based on
incredibly little bits of information
which are tantalisingly accurate in one
sense but once we have them you know
it's hard to override them so here's a
famous experiment on the self-fulfilling
prophecy that happens from this first
impression that you create or the
experimenter creates so a famous study
where elementary school children gave a
test to students the researcher said
we're going to tell you whether this
student is going to have we believe
based on our research at Harvard a good
or bad year okay so your elementary
school teacher and you wonder but they
say oh no we've done fantastic research
at Harvard where the top scholars in the
field and we've developed an algorithm
that tells you is the student gonna have
a good year or a bad year the teacher
gets that information back and at the
end of the year better scores for those
kids randomly described it's going to
have a good year
we're scores for those kids randomly
described as they're gonna have a bad
year now we don't you know they didn't
tape everything nowadays we could tape
everything but what can you guess that
happened and this might remind you of an
experiment we talked about with rats
except now it's children in school in
real life first impression right you
know when when you when you've been told
by a Harvard team of Harvard researchers
that some kid is gonna be slumpy and
they make a mistake answering a math
question you go hawai am i spending my
time on the students yeah they're that's
not worth my teaching skills right
somebody else answered gives a good
answer
what makes the same mistake and you go
oh we're gonna help the student you know
one there one inch away from being
perfect under multiplication table right
okay so the very same behavior gets
interpreted as pretty different
or maybe just remember when they gave
the right answer really well because you
think that's that student they got three
and four correctly but once you have
that first impression
all the other behaviors tend to be
interpreted in that context so one
category of things mixed into first
impressions that have been studied a lot
is is sort of consensus physical
attractiveness of course different
people think differently about physical
attractiveness but in the cultures we
live in there tends to be consensus
about the average movie star or beauty
contestant or whatever is the era's way
of people being seen so people have
shown again and again this will not
surprise you the physically attractive
people judge are judged as more
intelligent competent sociable and
normal and moral now why is that so
here's an example fifth grade teachers
were given report cards and photographs
of children they did not know the
photographs were picked to be a children
who looked by consensus to be attractive
or that consensus to be not so
attractive and they're asked to rate
based on the report cards and the photos
the intelligence and achievement of the
children the attractive children rate
what ended up a virtue a today's
brighter and more successful than the
unattractive children with identical
report cards right there sitting there
with all the information they're making
these sort of vague judgments the
attractiveness element even from the
photo is coming in to the teachers a
child's misbehavior it is attributed to
environmental circumstances if it's a
more attractive child and two
personalities it's a less attractive
child again this trade-off between
character and situation the attractive
child is something bad oh there must
have been something in this situation
that wasn't well done okay
the less attractive child this poorly
and you go oh that loser okay
yeah all right yeah I'm overstating but
you see how what's happening is
basically what we'll talk about a moment
court cases people have done Studies on
court cases shorter sentence for more
attractive people longer sentence for
less attractive people for what seem to
be comparable crimes so people call this
a halo effect that you take one positive
dimension of a person it could be any
physical attractiveness he's one of the
easiest ones to sort of experimentally
study and that once you say one thing is
positive you tend to rate other things
as positive it's just a human nature you
know she's likable so she's intelligence
you know he's attractive so he's smart
it's just
people do this it's you could argue it's
not a wise thing to do
an accurate thing to do definitely not
but people tend to do it they leak
categories once they have positive
information one dimension they start to
make positive assumptions on other kid
or dimensions all right and there's all
kinds of examples there's a thousand of
these studies because they're easy to do
and they're sort of popular to do but
anyway so here's one example where they
were told that the goal was to study
teacher evaluations and what they really
saw where's videos of a lecture of a
person with a strong Belgian accent so
this meant the accent matters for this
okay and they saw the videos of a person
answering questions in a warm and
friendly manner or a cold and distant
manner
okay this was done on purpose now in
these two videos they rated the person
in the worm the same person in one set
of videos and they were warm and
answering and the other one they were
called in distance the same person but
in two videos now they're asked to rate
other dimensions besides the warmness of
the person they said oh the person who's
warm was more attractive now it's
running the other way the nicer person
was more attractive more likeable and
kind of impressively has less of an
accent okay all right you already said
it's like because accents the trouble
with it - challenge of accents that
sometimes are a little hard to
understand right so you say how hard was
it to understand oh that nice person
handsome and pretty easy to understand
okay less a nice person buy on purpose
acting out you know not so attractive
and who could understand that thick
Belgian accent okay so it's did they
pick the exit because they say that's
ridiculous okay all these other I mean
it's ridiculous that an accent would
differ in the basis of whether a person
is nice or not but and so this is
thought to be the reason why you see so
many athletes and movie stars doing ads
because they're asking you to leak that
same way you know oh if Kobe Bryant uses
that deodorant that deodorant must be
awesome okay all right so that's why
they care that the celebrity there's
certain actors celebrities
that's why they have those ads because
many people have positive feelings about
them and if they can leak into accidents
that can certainly look into you know
what beer you drink or what makeup you
get right okay so
now one of this idea the problems with
these sort of when we might call
shortcuts to judging people first
impressions and that kind of stuff is
when we're making judgment other people
is that we do this very quickly and
unconsciously until you know you nobody
thinks if you ask them they go around
miss judging people by the basis of soup
very superficial things but a thousand
experiments show that an average we tend
to do that
so these stereotypes have what you know
effects once we make the decision it
influences our actual behavior so here's
one example where people tried to show
this idea that we might have some sort
of negative idea of somebody for some
reason now here's the self-fulfilling
prophecy because we have that negative
thought about them we don't behave with
them as nicely as we might now that
person who we haven't treated nicely of
course is responding to feeling like
they're not treating nicely and you go
haha you know just what I thought this
person stinks okay so you have this sort
of circle a positive or a negative
spiral and how you treat somebody how
they respond to the how you treat them
and then how you think more about them
so an example they did of this again
using through the sort of attractiveness
sort of dating discussion is they gave
in this case male participants pictures
that suggested a woman they were talking
to who they did not see was either more
or less conventionally attractive and
then they had a 10-minute conversation
back and forth then they brought in some
other males in this study and they asked
them to listen they don't know anything
about the experiment they just hear a
conversation and they say listen to this
conversation with this woman tells from
your impress how animated a she how
enthusiastic is she how much is she
enjoying herself in this conversation
and this will not surprise you in fact
it's in some sense it's almost trivial
but and the more attractive condition
now that the Raiders don't know that
they don't know anything they just hear
discussion going back and forth the
women were more sociable poised humorous
and socially adept they were rated that
way by the Raiders why because the men
who got the more attractive pictures
were being nicer in their conversational
style the women
spawning having a better conversation
back and forth and so this is an example
of the cycle between you know in this
case random and misleading information
and the behavior you have so that and
then once you have that thing you know
really start to alter the situation that
impression changes how you behave the
other person responds to that behavior
and you know that's kind of
self-fulfilling style um okay
let me switch for just a couple minutes
to talk about this idea we mentioned
before that the vast majority of
experimental psychology the kind I just
described to you is conducted in what
people call weird societies Western
educated industrialized rich and
impoverished countries it's just not you
know there's no research there's no
places to do it or support to do it
so the tremendous amount of research
comes from some countries like the
United States Europe Australia Japan you
know in the new coming years more and
more will come of course from China and
India South America and Africa probably
after that now it happens that the
countries that produce a lot of the
research are the countries that when
people study societal added towards
towards individuality versus sort of
fitting in the United States
parts of Europe Australia are in the
extreme in the world in emphasizing
individuality fat the United States has
seen as a fantastic outlier among other
cultures maybe maybe Canada is close and
here's a model that social psychologists
talk about and it's a very simple story
in a way but and certainly it's
averaging across lots of people so a
trouble with cultural psychology which
is where we're at now you can do one of
two things you can say culture doesn't
matter which we think is probably
unlikely right cultures are huge the
culture of your home your community your
country your religion all those things
influence people but then when you study
it you tend to reduce it to simple
things that people can sort of
experimental eyes and you tend to in
some sense stereotype it but anyway the
idea is that cultures that emphasize
individuality say oh you've got to be
yourself and then you have some people
you know around you you got to deal with
okay but be yourself follow you know
move across the country follow that
opportunity be the one and that
countries that emphasize interdependent
relations are much more talking about
you will fulfill yourself to the extent
that you find some sort of synergy with
those people who surround you and so
when they've done more organized studies
and I'll show you now you know on ads on
average say say and most of this
research previously has been in Japan
and South Korea or relative the United
States but it's spreading to other
countries you know many ads and Japan
will focus on groups enjoying themselves
and the US version is you know you're
special you're the one you know be all
that you can be it's you you you and
individuation and you know most of us on
average are brought up in this culture
we zip across the country you know
leaving people pursuing opportunities to
be ourselves you know sleeping
arrangements in other countries or in
the US tend to emphasize this beginning
text books Dixie Dixie dick Riley
Jane is somewhere in the story but you
know and so I'll just I'll leave these
notes for you but it's a teddy again
it's independent that what counts is
that you're independent or what counts
is that you fit in with others what's
what's the important thing so it's very
hard in these kinds of studies like with
ads or anything else to talk about
cultures as a whole things are very
complicated the worlds are different in
different countries or anything like
that so people have try to do these very
simple experiments I'll show you to try
to convince you that the most
fundamental level very fundamental
levels depending on the culture you come
from your mind is tuned to see the world
one way or the other way relatively
speaking and there's variations within
cultures of course how do but here's a
very simple experiment they show you a
box like this with a line the size of
the box and the line change from trial
to trial they take it away and now you
see an empty box the empty box could be
the same size or bigger or smaller and
they say draw a line that's either has
the absolute same size as this even
though the box is different or in other
trials I say draw so it has the same
relative the same ratio the same
relative size that makes sense all right
so here you know this would be the same
absolute size the same relative size
here this would be the same absolute
same relative size or absolute does that
make sense
okay that's all your job is draw a line
and you're told as it's taken away draw
it the same absolute size in the box or
the same relative size same ratio to the
box so here's the first thing to show
you which isn't on average people in
Japan are more accurate when they're
drawing this is mean error so it's good
to be low they're more accurate for the
relative size people in the US for the
absolute size I mean I think that's kind
of amazing a line in a box and we know
that's not culturally talk you know in
the United States we don't have anybody
good anything to say be all that you can
be you know draw that line in absolute
lengths right okay so the idea is it's
not a taut thing it's a way of thinking
I mean when you get a new example you
apply your culturals way of thinking
many people much of the time how
malleable is that is that fixed in you
from birth or not and then and then you
will help me discover the one flaw in
the study so they here's again the
absolute size here's the book you know
here's the Americans in America having
the reverse direction
here's Americans who are students
graduate students typically who have
been in Japan for a year or two
here's Japanese graduate students who
you know States for a year or two for
studies and you can see that just a year
or two makes the Americans look like the
Japanese in Japan and a year or two
makes the Japanese look like Americans
in America that makes that okay so one
interpretation is this is shockingly
malleable I mean 20 years 24 years of
one culture you know I'm one or two
years later you're shifted into the
mindset of the other culture and maybe
that's true if you are a very hard-nosed
researcher what do you wish would have
happened in a study to convince you
that's true yeah
sorry you could think about that yeah
that's not the way I'm thinking I know
I'm doing 20 questions so yeah that
would be a part of the story let me ask
you this one the students who where you
go if you go to the MIT and say please
all students from Japan come and
participate or you go somewhere in Tokyo
and say please all students from the US
come and participate is that a random
assignment no maybe the American
students who want to spend time in Japan
are kind of culturally attuned would
Japan that's why they went there and
maybe they you know are easily swayed by
that because that's why they're there
and maybe maybe these Japanese students
on average are swayed by American mores
because they came to the US because they
kind of like that way of thinking right
so to really convince yourself this is
really true you want to do random
assignments where two people come up to
you from the US and go okay you go to
Japan you know you stay in Flagstaff
okay all right but nobody will agree to
do that reasonably so so we just have to
make this impression from but but a
suggestion that cultural things could be
pretty malleable and a brain imaging
study that suggests for this line and
box tasks that it's harder work for
people from East Asia to do the absolute
task there's more activation working
harder to the absolute task and for
people from United States working harder
to do the relative task it's like it's
not that you can't see both as you sit
there you understand what a relative
size and what an absolute sight is it's
just harder to take the culturally
non-preferred perspective so here's um
here's a kind of weird experiment like
this so knowing now what you know
imagine you walked up to people on
average from Japan South Korea China or
on average born and grew up in the in
the United States and you said to them
here's a funny question which is your
favorite shape here the diamond or the
square if you're a rugged United States
Marine Corps individualist okay which
one do you like
who's the individualist in this picture
the diamond okay I'm a diamond and just
stand back right who see we're all
trying to get aligned here correctly
help each other be interdependent and
form a greater shape from our synergy
the squares okay as ridiculous as that
is or here's the is a here's the
triangle here's a one shape wrong and
different ears that triangles as
ridiculous as that question is a simple
non cultural as it feels people from the
US like the outstanding figure people
from Korea tend to like the more typical
figure okay here's another one this was
done in the airport imagine your Airport
this was in a days before 9/11 so we
weren't as worried about people running
around airports running up to us here's
how they literally did it at the San
Francisco Airport they would ask you
where you're from when you go if you
were from the US or from Japan or Korea
they would open a pencil box like you
might have had as a little kid and
there'd be a set of pencils in there and
they'd go please take one and your first
thought is okay what's the deal what's a
scam yeah are there any security people
around here I think oh no no just please
take a pencil and go okay and you take
one you think something Bad's gonna
happen it doesn't all they want to know
is this do you take the out the
individualists pencil or the
collectivists pencil okay and there's
some there's a one in four condition or
a two and three condition which pencil
do you take ridiculous as this
experiment is but it depends where you
come from
he stations on average picked pick the
majority pen and people born in the u.s.
European Americans picked minority pen
the standout individualists pen so to
ludicrous degree I mean the experiments
are almost too cute but but the ideas
they want to get rid of a lot of
cultural overlay and say you're just
picking a pencil you know it's not
something that anybody taught you at
home or in school how to be or how to do
here's a similar one they would show a
fish a picture like this is an example
picture first thing would ask people to
describe the picture and they noticed in
you know that the North Americans tended
to focus on the fish there's a really
big one he's gonna eat the really small
one you know that's the way of
capitalism I'm being facetious all right
but they're their story was on the fit
on a vertical and on average the people
they study from Japan you know talked
about not only the fish but the plants
background and things like this on
average okay that's just the average
description then they give them a memory
test for the fish where the fish had the
same background the same context they
were in or the no background or they got
a new background until we could take a
look at the accuracy if it's the
original background so if you saw if you
kind of took him the fish with the
background the context people from Japan
did better than people for the United
States if it's no background the
individual fish you've stripped away the
background it exactly reverses and who
does better with no background the
people from the United States right so
such a simple thing like this again it
seems to be driven by this here's one
market you could say yeah which is more
similar to this so this is similar buy
one stand out rule the common stem these
actually share more similarities if you
talk about the shape of the flower or
the shape of the petal but they're kind
of different one from the other and
again the European Americans go for the
one stand out that stem looks solid to
me okay that's the European Americans
and here's these stations not completely
reversed but tending to pick the ones
that have the more contextual similarity
so it's you know here's half dozen
examples and there's a hundred more and
so how that influenced us to
that many of the conclusions throughout
this course including the ones in social
psychology focused on people from North
American your you know universities so
let's talk about some of these ones so
for example we talked about the
fundamental attribution error it turns
out that the US is really big on this
even it's a little bit worldwide but the
u.s. is an outlier we really like to
attribute the actions of others to their
characters and not their situations the
attractiveness bias very pronounced the
United States compared to East Asians so
we really a gent you know find that one
outstanding thing and generalize it okay
and of course there's variations within
each culture right of course but these
these cultural teachings that you know
seem to manifest themselves a
these experiments any questions on that
okay what for the last few minutes I
want to talk about was a disorder that
you hear a lot about and you know if you
have questions I can answer some
questions on so autism you know when I
was a graduate student here you
practically never heard of it
now when you go to the pediatricians
office practically every parent is
worried about it for their child used to
be thought of as a very rare disorder
autism spectrum disorders are now
thought to be occur you know one out of
every something like that approaching 1%
okay have you seen the ads on TV by the
odds of having autism versus the odds of
making the NBA have you seen any of you
seen that okay incredibly higher by far
you know to have autism than to make the
NBA or many other things you can think
of it
you know they're just off ISM awareness
efforts to just make people realize it's
shockingly common lots of arguments of
the why there's been a dramatic increase
I can tell you that for a while they
thought it was awareness only that
people didn't realize that certain
children were best understood as having
autism spectrum disorders a range of
disorders that share some properties of
different difficulties in social
cognition communication and stereotyped
repetitive movements but now most
epidemiologic you can't really do the
experiment but most people think there
truly is an increasing number for
reasons that are not well understood on
top of increasing awareness nowadays
that can diagnose it by age three a huge
mystery is why there's four boys to
every girl with autism as far as people
have observed a total mystery nobody has
any idea why that is so I'm gonna show
you a few things that have been found
with individuals with autism so one
thing is in terms of individuals with
autism don't seem to have the natural
desire to socially interact with their
parents their siblings or caretakers
it's hard to get them to do what's easy
for most infants which is interact with
people around you
it's easy for most infants hard for
people with autism this is eye tracking
when people so this is a path that you
look at when you look at somebody else
and what's very common as we look at
people is that we focus a lot of our
attention to other people's eyes well
that makes sense
you know that from your everyday
experience you okay you look at the
mouth and a year here and there but as
the eyes or the other person that seem
very communicative socially and so you
see the sort of triangle where people go
between the mouth the speaking mouth and
the eyes naturally to figure out what's
going on with a person his typical
person with autism you see it's like
they don't even look at this I don't
focus on the eyes don't focus on the
eyes the original interpretation of this
was a lack of interest in looking at
these faces as social targets there's an
additional thought that maybe for some
individuals are many with autism there's
something uncomfortable with dealing
with a social agent or a person
so that's eye tracking and by the way
the same thing when they were this is
spontaneous the first picture wherever
you want to look now they said tell us
what the expressionist so you have a
task to do and again pretty much like
before typically developing people focus
on the eyes a little bit in the mouth
and again you can see these very wayward
locations of where individual autism put
their glances so you can justly mention
a very different social interaction if
somebody's looking here or here at
somebody versus the person's eyes
there's been a fantastic amount of
research about what our brain
differences in people with autism
spectrum disorders and those without
there's a trim fantastic variation among
like every disorder but you might say
autism even more or every difference
autism even more it seems like there's
just a fantastic variation among people
with autism but the one finding that's
held up is this which is that if you
measure the total brain size which is a
very gross measure of the brain right
that there seems to be an early and
develop up until age 5 an overgrowth at
the brain size individuals with autism
that sort of gets back in development to
the typical size this is the most
replicated every number here is a
different research study
you can see all of these up here sort of
clumps here this is the single most
replicable finding by far in autism
there's an early apparent overgrowth of
the brain what that means why that's
associated with difficulties in social
interaction or repetitive stereotypes
with repetitive movement stereotypes
interests it's hard to know really in
the course we mentioned them we've
talked about theory of mind
understanding what another thoughts and
other person holds and sometimes it's
not even consistent with the physical
real world I mentioned to you that this
severely delayed this delayed in autism
year you know years later so this is
comparing four-year-olds typically
developing four six or twelve year old
with autism and the four-year-olds
outperform the individual autism and
theory of mind tasks alright so huge
delay in understanding what the
independent mental life is like of
another person yeah so so the question
is how are I fused in autism so the
answer is if you measured height so half
of individuals autism are nonverbal you
can't even give them a test okay those
are not the ones who tend to be
represented in research because
behavioral research or brain research
because you can't even ask them to do
things so we all the research is skewed
towards the higher functioning
individuals autism if you just took
their average IQ it would be lowish okay
but there's many individuals with very
high IQs also so an in fact a spurt
what's called Asperger's syndrome
specifically refers to individuals who
have the social difficulties
characteristic of autism but have a very
high-functioning cognitive and IQ level
so it runs the whole range if you if you
just did the average of below but
there's many individuals who are very
high in IQ and so in this study for
example they matched IQ by having in
this case four-year-olds and six to
twelve year olds the IQ was even and
still the theory of mine was much weaker
in the individuals with autism but it's
incredibly variable the IQs
so here's another way that people have
studied two things at once we'll talk
about the human nature to ascribe social
things social stories to things and then
how that plays have different autism so
this is work famous where from hydrants
MO and you're gonna see these two
triangles do something and I want you to
figure out what they're doing okay what
happened there
socially and you tell me put their hand
up and than other people who helped me
on some people your hand up so anyway
you thought you saw second last chord
lecture the whole person got to have
somebody okay what do you think you saw
they're kind of dancing anything else
yeah
yeah comment there's no right answer by
the way when I heard here which is
coaxing that the little one was scared
to go there playing together they're
having a nice relationship then the
little one doesn't wanna go outside the
box and the big one has to coax and
support them were you gonna say that to
any other thoughts or okay all right so
yeah they're the most common
interpretation of this and hydrants
emblem their original point was the
humans want to give social descriptions
to everything you know to triangles what
are you talking about but almost if we
just let our mind go just a little bit
we're almost giving them anima see
they're removing themselves around
they're having social interactions you
they have stories where there's there's
sometimes there's a bully beating up the
little you know big circle beating up a
little circle or damn you know yeah we
tend to make up these little stories
very easily so the first thing to tell
you is that individual with autism on
average you can a big range on the
average don't see these stories okay so
much they say they say on average like
they're two triangles what do you mean
you know and you could say that's not
even wrong it's just not the way people
typically interpret things that we
typically look for socially and then you
look in the brain and what happens is
this this is brain responses to these
social stories where we tend to give it
a social explanation versus random this
place they can also displace where
things are whizzing around and nobody
thinks anything's happening okay and
what they see is in the visual cortex
this part of the brain that sees the
things there's equal activation in the
two groups but in parts of the brain
that we think are involved in social
interaction like the superior temporal
sulcus medial prefrontal cortex areas
from a lot of research that we believe
is involved in thinking about other
people and their feelings and thoughts
there's very little engagement of these
areas and individuals with autism in the
study so they don't see the same stories
and they don't turn on social parts of
the brain that are spontaneously turn on
by typically developing people and
here's the last experimental I'll show
you which is this so it turns out our
brains respond and our minds respond
very strongly to where people are
looking where their gaze is falling so
imagine that you're talking to somebody
you know you're telling them something
their eyes are here does that bother you
okay yes okay because we think their
eyes tell us where their attention is
and if they're not focused on us they're
not interested right again we're
offended okay so here's the experiment
now where they have a computer model
like this they throw on suddenly a
display and the person either looks this
way or looks the opposite which would
you think is the natural way a person
would look naturally if something
interesting happened over here they
would look towards it right it'd be kind
of weird to look away from it and when
you look in brain imaging it what
happens in those conditions in the
superior temporal sulcus and other
places typically developing people for
the weird looking away it's like a
mystery to be solved what's going on why
aren't they looking at this you know are
they angry or this is something better
over there there's a social mystery why
is this person not look you know and
there's no difference in those two
conditions in the study for individuals
with autism as if you know eyes are
looking here eyes are looking there hmm
it's just where eyes are looking what's
the difference all right it's there's
there's not the spontaneous social
interpretation or mystery that needs to
be understood so these are just some of
the differences that people have
observed looking at the brains and
behavior of people awesome any questions
about autism yeah
yes the question is now that's a good
question
do those those parts of the brain the
areas that we in typical people are
turned on for social and cognition when
we think about what another person is
thinking or feeling
do they ever turn on individual autism
the answer is yes they do I can tell you
that I'm showing you some of the
simplest things and probably roughly
correct but there's such a fantastic
variety among people with autism and
even within the person just a very
little bit of different of a condition
all of a sudden some of these ears will
turn on it's it's been a very big
mystery and we don't know whether that's
because we just don't understand it
right or whether the variety among
patients is so great that we're making
the wrong conclusions saying autism is
like this and there may be true a 5% of
individuals with autism so it's a huge
mystery in many ways and an important
one because all of a sudden it's almost
1 percent one out of every hundred
children
you